>>Daniels Lee: Hello everybody.
My name – well before we get started, I
just wanted to take a moment and as people
are still filing in, I want to welcome everybody
to Google I O.
This is our very first Geo session of I O
and so I feel very privileged to be up here.
I'm very excited to deliver to you guys some
information about some really important stuff
that's happening around our Google Maps API's.
And this particular session is going to primarily
focus on giving you a lot of information and
incentive and motivation to really start thinking
about migrating over your Version 2 map applications
over to use Version 3.
And I'm going to cover a lot of information
and topics around this.
So my name is Daniels Lee.
I work on the Developer Relations Team here
at Google and I'm one of the fortunate few
who are happy to support our Google Maps API's
and this includes not just V-2 and V-3 but
Flash and Static and Maps and our Geocoding
services as well.
So before we begin, I do want to note and
I'm sure you guys may be aware of this – there
was a slide that was displaying a link to
the Google Wave sessions for every session
at I-O.
So I would encourage you as the session goes
on to go ahead and you can open up your laptops
and you can look at this wave and submit some
questions as we go along as you have them.
There'll also be a live note taker which will
be taking place as I speak and so this is
just a link that you guys can go to and feel
free to submit questions and I'll – at the
end of the session, I'll be – I'll try to
be mindful of the time and, and answer them.
[pause]
What am I gonna talk about today?
So here's some session – here's the agenda
for my session.
So first I'm gonna talk about some session
goals.
Why are we here?
What are you here to learn?
And what is some information that I want to
leave you with when you go?
And then I want to dive into a brief – a
really brief summary of V2 because I think
it's important to understand the contrast
and give perspective on why – what the differences
are between V2 and V3.
And then I'm gonna jump into V3.
Why V3?
Why did we build it?
Why would you want to migrate?
And then we'll go into some, some tips and
tricks and things to think of ahead of time
to start this migration.
And then the last portion of the, of the session
will be a little bit more of a technical dive
into this and I'll show you some codes and
bits and some very specific parts which I
think would help with the migration overall.
So before I begin, I actually wanted to share
a quote that is actually meaningful to me
and I think it's relative to this talk which
is, "Knowledge is the antidote to fear" and
basically I think change can be scary and
anytime you upgrade from an old system to
a new system, there can be – it can be a
little bit intimidating, right?
There's a new software API, there's a new
API they have to learn or there's, there's
things that may break along the way and, and
there's all this information you have to learn.
So hopefully by providing you with a lot of
information and knowledge about this migration
that it'll help remove some of this fear in
getting this process started.
I think the hardest part is getting started
but I'm assuming by being here in this session,
you've already sort of begun that process.
So what are my session goals?
I want to provide you guys with an incentive
to migrate, give you guys some advice and
insight around how to migrate your version
2 apps over to V3.
Start thinking about migration sooner rather
than later.
It'll help save on development costs in the
future.
If you have a very large V2 app already and
you're thinking about adding new features
to it, you're, you're using that development
time to build those features for an API that,
that is sort of an older system and you may
have to migrate later on anyway.
So I want you to understand the benefits of,
of why you'd want to migrate.
And lastly, I do want to reiterate what you,
what you guys want to expect – what do you
expect to happen as you migrate?
What are some of the challenges involved in
doing that?
So again, just to reiterate why you'd want
to attend this session.
I do want to make it clear that there are
some assumptions I have about the people who
are attending this and I'm assuming you are
a V2 developer or at some point have used
the Google Maps API's and you are familiar
with certain basic maps concepts like maps
and overlays and controls and so forth.
Anyone who's interested in building a map
application in the future or has that in mind,
if you want to learn more about V3 and what
some of the differences are, you're all, you're
all here for the right reasons then.
Next I want to really quickly show up a Geo
landscape sort of diagram because I realize
as our Google Maps, as Geo in general has
grown significantly over the past years or
so at Google – at Developed Products, we've
begun to have so many that it's hard to keep
track of.
And so here's a diagram that just quickly
shows where the Maps API for V3 – where
that sort of lies in correlation to all the
rest.
[pause]
Okay.
So next moving on, I want to really briefly
go over a summary of V2.
I'm assuming a lot of you already have experience
in working with V2 so I will try to make this
quick but I do think it's important to go
over what things about V2 currently exist
today.
So V2 has a very strong browser support.
It supports even older browsers such as IE6
and Firefox2 and even Safari3.
It's got extremely strong developer community.
We have over 350,000 active sites today which
is a true testament to how much [bad audio]
the product really is.
It's a core part, it's a core part of many
people's businesses, business models.
In order to do that, V2 also has a versioning
system which allows you to specify a stable
version if you want your app to continue – to
not really change much.
But you can also choose to load in an experimental
version as well if you want to stay at the
cutting edge and get these new features and
new bugs are getting fixed.
V2 also has a bunch of utility libraries which
are all open sourced meaning anyone including
you guys – anyone can contribute to this
project.
And utility libraries are basically – essentially,
they are extensions of the core API – stuff
that for a variety of reasons were not able
to be included in the core and, and people
have built on top of that.
There's different ways you can interact with
the UI and create in different ways.
V2 also has a really strong developer community
like I said.
We have about 43,000 members currently and
the developer community has some really, really
advanced apps and API developers – people
who really have a lot of experience with mapping
software in general and it's an incredibly,
incredibly great resource to have as a tech
– for technical support if you have questions
or there are certain discussions that you
want to talk about.
I would encourage everyone if you're not part
of that community yet – I would encourage
you to go visit the groups on Groups dot Google
dot com.
[pause]
So really quickly I want to list out some
of the really big and core features of V2
because that is probably one of its strongest
assets – it's get an incredibly strong feature
set, right?
So Google Maps API at V2 has Street View,
it has traffic overlays and has even a Google
Earth Plug-in which allows users to view Google
Maps in 3D directly within a browser which
is pretty incredible.
In addition to these, you may be familiar
with all the other ones, right?
So we have KML overlays and Tile Overlays
– you can create a really customizable
mapping experience for your users.
If you have a website and your branding is
very important to you, you can re-brand the
map and, and use custom markers and custom
controls to have it suit the same UI and stylize
your website.
One of the other main points I want to bring
up -- with V2, you can also monit—it also
has monetization features.
So if you wanted to have – you wanted to
generate revenue from your website which is
drawing in a lot of traffic basically – you
got really good content on there.
Users want to come back.
You can monetize your map applications either
by using what we call GoogleBar or MapsAdUnit
and it's basically displaying ads based on
search or based on content which your map
view point is currently displaying.
And the last big launch of V2 was aerial imagery.
And this was – this sort of angled perspective
that you have instead of this bird's eye,
top-down view of the map.
So that was really cool.
But you guys know this already.
You guys already have experience using V2
so let's move on to why we're here.
Let's talk about V3 a little bit.
Before we start that off I wanted to show
really 2 demos.
The first demo is more for you guys to explore
on your own.
With mobile phones, one of the biggest reasons
why V2 was, was designed and released is to
focus on mobile performance, to create a Maps
API that was fast and lightweight enough to
be able to run well on mobile browsers.
So you can load up those 2 links which basically
points to just a simple map – no features
added to it and you can load that map on your
mobile phone and compare what the performance
difference is like.
Meanwhile, I'm gonna switch over to one of
my first demos which is basically displaying
a – the performance of adding a bunch of
markers on using the V2 API and then I'm gonna
compare that speed – how long that took
and compare that using the V3.
So here's a map that has nothing on it yet
but if I can click on these links, then I
can say load a hundred markers on it and I
can time that operation.
You can see here that it takes about roughly
250 milliseconds to do that.
There may be – that's kind of an estimate.
If I move that up to 300, the time's gonna
get longer.
And it's gonna get longer if I go 500 – takes
a little bit over a second, right.
And I can go on to maybe 750, a thousand will
take probably significantly longer.
So I guess I'll leave it at that.
Seven hundred fifty markers – it took about
2.2 seconds to load on V2.
If I switch over to V3 and I run the same
tests, you can already tell that the markers,
the operation is taking much quicker – it's
taking less time for it to load.
So if I load 500 markers, it's taking 700
milliseconds and if I go to that same stopping
point – 750 – it takes roughly about 1.3
seconds in comparison.
And contrast that to V2.
So that's one sort of illustration of the
performance benefits that you'll have if you
use V3 as an API instead of V2.
This test also uses one of our utility libraries
which is called Market Clusterer because realistically
when would you ever want to display a thousand
markers and if you are going to do that, I
would probably encourage you guys to use some
sort of a clustering library.
So I can enable clustering here and rerun
these, these tests and you can see that it's
significantly faster.
So this is one of the benefits of using a
clustering library for example which is a
utility library and not part of the core.
Again pointing out how useful they actually
are.
So loading a thousand markers using a cluster
takes less than half of a second and that's
in V2.
In V3, it's – oh, let me enable Market Clusterer
first.
So loading 500 – it's incredibly fast and
takes a fraction of a second compared to V2.
So 380 milliseconds versus 30 – that's,
that's pretty significant.
So going back – what are some of the problems
that, with V2 that I wanted to highlight?
And I think the demo helped me lead up to
what we wanted to talk about – I wanted
to talk about performance.
Performance is one of the biggest reasons
why V2 exists today – what we really focused
on when we rebuilt it from the ground up.
And V2 is not really optimized for mobile.
It's not optimized because we don't really
test fully in the browser, in mobile browsers
for V2.
It's not really meant to run in a mobile browser.
You can but performance will be pretty slow.
It's also got an older design.
It has these obscure class names like GMap2
or GLatLng or GMarker which exist in the global
name space.
And one of the things you may have noticed
about V2 is that the Gmap 2 object is constantly
growing or has grown to be extremely big and
it's this giant, giant object with all of
these methods in it.
So it's really bloated with these methods
and that's because of the architecture – the
way V2 was designed.
It also had larger Java script download sizes
and this, this impacts performance, right?
This impacts – if you're on a – the difference
between downloading an 85K file or a bunch
of files to initialize your map – that versus
let's say a 30K is going to be pretty significant
when you're browsing on your mobile phone.
And lastly the Maps API Version 2 also required
a Maps API key which was a unique key which
is generated based on your domain.
And I've had support issues with this.
I've had people who had trouble identifying
what is the correct domain to generate against
because they have sub-domains and like they
have questions.
"If I generate from the parent, is that going
to traverse through and be valid for all domains
beneath it?"
So those are some of the things about V2 which
I think can be seen as problematic.
And really quickly I want to show the performance
table chart which basically takes apart the
initial download and it really is split up
into 3 files.
It's the loader which then loads in a main
dot js which defines all of your core objects
in the Maps API.
And then it has the tiles.
The tiles are the images that you see which
make up the visualization of the map.
And in V2, it takes about, it's about 85K
in a Gzip file.
So let's talk a little bit similarly about
V3 now and what V3 offers in contrast to V2.
So V3 has mobile browser support meaning we
test, we rigorously test in every release
that we have in V3 against popular mobile
browser phones which includes Android and
IPhone.
So V3 is very performance oriented.
We're always thinking is this going to run
well in mobile and if not, how can we get
it to be?
So it's lightweight.
It's got a smaller initial download size and
a lot of the ways that makes this, that makes
this possible to improve the performance in
this way is because of the MVC architecture
that, that V3 uses.
M-V-C stands for Model View Controller and
it's a UI framework which really promotes
and allows you to create a modular, more robose,
more robust design for an API.
It's got a cleaner name space as well so you
don't have these obscure Gmap 2 objects anymore.
You'll have a Google dot maps dot so-and-so
so your global name space will stay freer.
And we also have new features and that are
exclusive to the V3 API which are not available
in V2.
And some of these are biking directions and
elevation service.
Excuse me.
So the same chart for V3 in terms of the initial
download size.
You can see it's cut down from 85K to 30K.
That's, that's about a third of the size that
it takes to initialize a map in V2 which,
which is actually a significant difference
when you're browsing a map on your mobile
phones.
Part of how this is possible too with V3 talking
about the MVC architecture, making it more
modular, you can actually have these features
that are loaded more incrementally.
And they're loaded as they're needed so this
will help keep that initial download size
really small.
So looking back.
I think it's been a really, really exciting,
exciting year for V3 and it's, it's experienced
a tremendous, tremendous growth and is still
growing and has an incredible forward momentum
right now which is why I think it's an extremely
exciting time for the V3 API.
And I really do want to commend the API engineers
in Sydney for working to make this possible.
They really cranked out a lot of features
in just over a year.
V3 – Google had launched V3 into Code Labs
last year at Google I O in 2009 and since
then, we've been moving this forward direction
to ultimately reach full feature parity with
V2 – have every feature that's available
in V2 and make it available in V3 plus more.
So the red highlighted features on this, this
diagram indicates the ones that are actually
exclusive to V3 and are not available in V2
right now – so things like Elevation Service
like I mentioned before and more recently
Bicycling Layers and Bicycling Directions.
So these are some – this is just a really
cool way to just look back at a year and see
the amount of progress that we made.
And so you may be wondering – like what's
the next step?
What is the next step from here?
I have a really, really important announcement
to make and it's an extremely exciting announcement.
And I'm dying to tell everybody about it.
So I'm really happy and I feel privileged
to be able to tell all you guys about it and
maybe you can guess what that is.
But yeah, we even have shirts, right?
[audience voice] [inaudible]
Yeah.
So as you may have guessed – Google Maps
– the Version 3 of Google Maps API is graduating
from Google Code Labs.
This is huge.
[applause]
We have our engineers over there and really
want to commend them on, on the incredible
work that they've done over the past year
to make this possible.
So what does this mean?
If you're not familiar with Google Code Labs,
Google Code Labs is basically a developer
market, a developer place where we can – it
allows Google to put up developer products
that are still early, that are still in their
early stages of development – so not ready
for full usage yet.
It's a place for innovation.
It's great for both Google engineers and for
you, external developers, because it allows
you to really test out these new and amazing
technologies that people have these ideas
for and allow to, allow you guys to experiment
with it.
So what is significant, what are some of the
changes that's gonna happen?
How's this gonna impact V3?
Well, there's a lot of really good stuff here.
Because V3 has now graduated from Labs, it
shows a long term commitment for this product.
We have a really dedicated team, an amazing
team, a very bright, innovative team that
has a lot of focus that will be moving all
that focus to making V3 be even better.
So there's going to be increased attention
and support for this product.
We've also reorganized and revamped our documentation
to reflect these changes and which you will
be able to see.
It should be up by the end of the day.
And we will also be including a new versioning
system because how can you have a full product
if you don't allow people to view the stable
version of it.
And so this is going to be our primary Maps
APIs from now on.
Also, it's kind of bittersweet but this also
means that V2 is going to be deprecated.
Now what does it mean for V2 to be deprecated?
Well it's not going anywhere.
Your V2 apps are still going to be, be working,
right?
So we have a deprecation policy.
It will be working for at least the next 3
years.
And what kind of support will we have for
it?
Well, we'll definitely gonna be continuing
to fix bugs as they come up but we won't be
introducing any new features in V2 and you
may have already noticed a slower growth that
V3 has been launching new features – it's
been on this upward curve and V2 has been
kind of on a flat line.
And that's because the team's focus is gonna
be on V3 now.
And one other thing you may have noticed – all
the Geo sessions here at Google I O this year
will be focusing on V3.
So there's lots more opportunities for you
guys to learn more information about this.
But overall, this is a really, really exciting
announcement and happy to share with all of
you.
Moving on to – so now you have reasons why,
you understand some of the incentives – clearly
I've been, I've been talking a lot about performance.
V3 is faster; it's more lightweight; it's
better for mobile and now it's, it's out of
Google code labs and so really, really there's
no time better than now to start migrating
your apps.
And so let's look at some of the V3 features
that currently exist today.
Well talking about browser support.
V3 supports all the major browsers but it
also includes mobile browsers, right?
It includes Android for example.
You'll notice that we don't have IE6 and Firefox2
or Safari3 on this list which doesn't mean
it won't work or it'll stop working.
It just means we'll be focusing most of our
support towards these major browsers and we'll
try our best to make it work in IE6 as well
but there are some things about just technology
in general where you kind of have to draw
a line at some point.
In terms of the versioning scheme, if you
want to learn more about the versioning scheme,
there's, there's more of this on the documentation
which will be published by the end of today.
But basically you'll be able to specify similarly
to V2 a way to get the bleeding edge, the
latest version that's currently been released
which includes the latest bug fixes and the
latest feature releases but it's going to
be more experimental, right?
It's going to be – it might have more bugs
in it.
Your application may not always work or may
break something.
We might have regression bugs but it will
also give you the ability to specify an older
version if you do want a more frozen version
that changes less frequently.
V3 also has a growing utility library – Open
Source Project – similar to V2 and we are
-- expect this to grow much more over the
next few months.
There's going to be a lot more features that
we're going to try to push out to this.
So lastly, there's a developer community which
is also growing rapidly in my opinion and
it currently has 15,000 members today.
And so i you guys are not part of that, I
would also encourage you guys to please join
as well.
Some of the, what are some of the features
that V3 has?
Well, we're almost – I wouldn't say we were
100% full feature parity up but we're really
close.
We're almost there.
We have a lot of all the big features that
have been carried over from V2.
So things like markers and overlays and custom
controls, and, and custom map types.
We have a client site Geo coder, a Direction
Service.
We have all the stuff that's already, that
has been ported over from V2 and in that porting
over, we've also done a lot of redesign and
made it much more intuitive.
We've really taken everything and sort of
took a step back.
We redesigned it, reevaluated it, seen what
the use cases are and ported them over.
So more recently we've also had a few more
launches with features which includes ground
overlays, KML layers, GeoRSS feeds, and traffic
layers.
And I talked about features that didn't exist
yet in V3 and these, some of these are bicycling
layers.
We have a new Elevation Service which allows
you to create elevation data on a map.
We also have Rectangle and Circle overlays
which are not available in V2.
And lastly, we have these things called MVC
objects and I'm going to be talking about
this a little later on and what you can do
with them but it's a very powerful way to
really create some very clean, efficient code
for your application.
And so what are some of the challenges that
exist when you're trying to port over your,
your V2 app over to V3?
These are just some points I think in my experience
– because I also as a developer had to
learn the V3 API back at one point and I remember
some of the difficulties that I ran into.
Well, obviously you are going to have feature
parity issues.
We're, we're almost there.
However, there are these very intricate use
cases that sometimes come up.
People have found some very interesting ways
to use the V2 API and even in ways that it
wasn't necessarily meant or designed to be
used.
So one example is, a more recent example came
up as I was supporting someone on line in
the, in the discussion group.
He had an issue where he wanted – in V2,
he took a hybrid map type and applied – he
wanted to apply an opaque background to it.
He wanted to put a black or a white background
which created this really nice effect and
it really highlighted the font, the, the full
color of the text that's being displayed.
He wanted to do this in V3 but in V2 we gave
you direct access to these tile layers.
So you can get the hybrid map type, access
the tile layer, change the background of it
and so forth.
But in V3, you don't, you don't, you don't
have this access yet.
So there's interesting use cases like this
which sometimes come up and this will happen
as you have more of these different things
that you're doing in your V2 app, right?
So there'll be some of that.
You guys already know about the syntactical
changes.
There's basically a new Google dot Maps dot
Namespace and all the different class names
is something that you're going to have to
learn.
But this is something that's relatively easy
to pick up, right?
It's just like sort of re-branding.
It's learning how to call certain functions
differently in V3.
And the API reference on our documentation
is incredibly useful for this.
And one thing I wanted to reiterate is that
V3, with V3 – that many times you look at
code and in V2, it is very easy to make a
lot with just a few lines of code.
And in V3, it may initially seem like, well
I have so many more lines here.
However, sometimes less code is not always
better, right?
Sometimes you have more structure – and
your code is more readable and so it's designed
in a better way.
It's more robust.
Another big change and a conceptual difference
which I think is really important to understand
is how overlays work differently in V3 versus
how they used to work in V2.
So overlays in V3 are basically – the way
it used to work in V2 you would have to have
the map add every overlay onto itself so that's
why you have all these add functions within
your map object.
You have an add overlay, you have add control,
you have an add map type, right?
And so every time you introduced a new feature
like this, that's why the map object had to
get really big and so there's this conceptual
difference where in V3 your overlays are no
longer being added to the map by the map – it's
adding themselves to the map.
It's essentially binding itself to a map that
you give it.
And so this, this, this prevents that problem
with your map object growing very big.
The last 2 points I want to, that you may
notice is there's just some differences with
the object specification request and response
specification in your Geo coding service,
in your Direction Service.
Elevation service is new so that's gonna be
a new topic.
But for those 2, expect those to be slightly
different and you need – there will be some
learning involved.
So some things to really quickly think about
when you're trying to port over your V2 app.
I think it's a great idea just to list out
whether in your head – probably better to
write it down a list of what features – what
big features that it currently uses.
Does it use street view?
Does it use Direction Service?
Does it use the Geo coding service?
And then think about all your intricate use
cases and, and you're gonna have to find out
– is this possible in V3, right?
Can I do this in V3?
And if not, what are you going to, what can
you do about that?
And this is, this is where I would encourage
you guys, well, if you don't see a feature
that's currently available in V3, we would
not have as much of a tremendous growth rate
as we've had over the last year if you guys
weren't as diligent about filing feature requests
and filing these bugs in our issue tracker
to let us know what is not working, to let
us know what features that you do want to
see.
So that's very important for you guys to do.
And then lastly, just take baby steps – start
with how you started building your V2 app.
Start with a map, then add a marker, then
place an Info Window, add some Geo coding
for example.
So I talked about getting, filing feature
requests and bugs and I think these are probably
going to be very important, 2 very important
places for you guys to know where to go.
You need to know where to go to get help and
you need to know where to file these feature
requests and bugs.
So these are the 2 locations – they are
in our Google groups –our discussion group
and our external issue tracker.
Okay.
So let's go into a little bit more technical
stuff.
There is no way I am going to be able to cover
every intricate use case or every feature
that we have in V3 in just one session.
V3 is just too big and there's too many things
you can do with it.
So I'm going to cover the ones that I think
are important to note and will help get you
started on this process.
Starting with the basics.
V2 API required a maps API key for you to
use your map.
V3 we got rid of this.
We realized we don't need this.
So in order to track usage for our services,
for our Geo coding for example, we use a client
IP address now and we don't, we don't need
you to go onto a site and figure out what
domain you have to use to generate this key
for.
So this is really good.
This is actually really useful.
There are some cases that I've seen where
people want – people are hosting their map
applications behind multiple domains and they
had to create this sort of Java script work
around to detect the domain that it's being
loaded on and then dynamically load the correct
API key, right?
So you don't have any problems like that anymore
in V3.
Second, I want to really briefly talk about
the sensor parameter.
This comes up once in awhile in a discussion
group and that's why – where it stops people
in its track.
Well, in our documentation we have this snippet
which allows – you love to copy and paste
but the sensor parameter, just make sure to
put in an actual value of either 'true' or
'false' because if not, then your Java script
library is not going to load and your app,
your objects will be undefined.
So make sure to do that.
Okay.
Really quickly – or maybe not.
Maybe you can take a moment and just try to
observe the difference here between V2 and
V3 – what does the code look like?
There's not so much of it here but this is
really all you need to display a simple map
with nothing on it.
Okay.
What are some of the differences that you
may have noticed?
So in V3, we have this options object – we
have an options specification which you'll
see is commonly used everywhere in the V3
API, with a lot of objects, with our maps,
with our markers, our Info Windows.
With our [ ] Geo coding you're going to have
this constructor with this object that has
a bunch of properties in it which will help
you, which will configure this object to do
different things, initialize it with different,
with different values.
So you'll expect to see that everywhere.
It's also got the name space.
It's got the google dot maps dot map object
instead of something like Gmap2 for example.
And lastly, the 3 required properties to get
nothing but a simple map up is a mapTypeId
which specifies your map type, a zoom level,
and a LatLng for your center point.
[pause]
Let's talk about overlays.
I said overlays were conceptually kind of
different in V3 versus V2 and they are and
I think it actually does make a lot of sense
and there are reasons why I also think it's
a better design as well.
So maps don't add overlays, right?
Not in V3.
The overlays are responsible for adding themselves
to the map.
So they're going to bind themselves to the
map by calling this setMap function and in
the set mapping, you're going to pass it the
map object that you want the marker to bind
itself to.
So this is just a really quick comparison
between what those functions – what were
the two functions that you had to call in
V2 to add, add a marker overlay to a map,
and then how does that look in V3.
The reason I have InfoWindow up here as well
is because in V3, InfoWindows are nothing
more than, than lightweight overlays.
Actually, they are overlays and I'll talk
about InfoWindows after this.
And so that's why you see them here as well.
So some of the, some of the things about overlays
before I show just a little snippet.
Well, overlays help to keep the initial – well
because it's binding itself to the map, right,
the map doesn't have to keep track of these
overlays and doesn't have to add more methods
every time it adds a new feature like this.
So it's better to keep the initial download
size – you can keep the core initial download
size low which is in the end also great for
mobile.
It's great for performance.
So this is actually what – this is just
an actual example of what a code snippet looks
like to add an overlay marker on to a map.
And also how to open up an InfoWindow in a
map.
As you can see in Version 2, that, the map
– it's the map object which is calling
an add overlay function or an open Info Window
function to open up these overlays onto itself.
Whereas in V3, these markers are adding themselves
to the map and the Info Window is opening
itself on to the map.
Well you know how to add overlays now.
How do you, how do you remove them?
Removing them is, is essentially the same
concept as just calling the setMap function
and unbinding it from the map that you had
binded it to previously.
You can do that by calling a setMap and passing
a null or passing a nothing in there.
And the Info Window has a close method as
you can here.
There's one interesting, there's one interesting
challenge though that came up in V3 because
the map no longer has a collection, right,
of overlay objects that it knows has been
added onto itself because it's not doing the
work anymore.
And so I challenge you guys.
There's this problem, right?
How do you remove all overlays from a map?
In V2, you had this clear overlays function
which people used and people wanted so badly
and they still want it.
However, I do want to give you guys the answer
– at least my answer which is pretty simple.
Well you can maintain your own collection
of overlays, right?
You guys, you know Java script.
You can create a global object and every time
you add an overlay on to a map, you add it
to the collection as well.
So maintaining means every time you add it,
you push it on.
Every time you remove it from the map, you
pop it off.
So maintaining – there's a few steps that's
involved to maintain this collection and lastly,
once you have this collection – well at
any moment, any user action, you can, you
can just iterate through this collection,
go through every overlay, and then unbind
every overlay from the map.
And that's essentially what we're doing here.
So you have an overlays collection which is
in the form of an array and it's sitting in
the global name space so it's accessible anywhere.
And as you add a marker, you're always pushing
a marker onto this collection.
Once you have that collection, you can iterate
through it and then call setMap and set its
map property to null.
And that'll remove the overlay –all overlays
from the map.
So talking really briefly, talking about Info
Windows quickly.
I did want to show one example of – well,
here's an Info Window demo.
It's not doing anything special here.
Every time I register an event listener on
the map.
So every time I click, it's going to create
an Info Window object and display it.
You guys – this is familiar to you.
You've seen this before in V2.
What you haven't seen is this, though – right
– where you can add an infinite number
of Info Windows onto a map.
In Version 2, you were limited to only have
one.
And Info Windows are a much more heavyweight
object back then – or in V2.
So Info Windows are essentially overlays in
V3 and they're lightweight; they're really
fast and you can have more than one of them.
However I've learned that sometimes too much
freedom is – can be overbearing and, and
so we have this new problem.
We have another problem here.
Well what if I want only a single Info Window?
And developers that come to us will be like,
'Wait. I didn't want this freedom. I only
want one Info Window.'
So how do you do this?
Well similarly to our overlays thing – I
think it's somewhat similar.
You can create a single Info Window object
which is accessible in the global name space
and then every time you want to open up an
Info Window, you basically can just update
– that Info Window's position, its content
and then you can even update its, its map
whichever map it's binded to.
So if you have multiple maps, you can swap
them out very easily.
So this is the answer to that problem.
If you want one, if you only want one Info
Window, create only one Info Window object.
The next thing I want to talk about is custom
controls really quick.
So what's different about custom controls
and how can you create a custom control V3?
How did you used to do it in V2?
In V2, you had to extend – you had to, you
had to extend this G control class and do
some things with that.
In V3, it's much, much more simpler.
In V3, it's basically – you're essentially
– your custom control is essentially an
HTML Element.
So the document dot createElement – you're
just creating a 'div' element and that 'div'
element is being placed into one of the control
positions on your map.
So this is already a familiar concept to you
guys, right?
Creating an HTML node and then setting poppies,
setting up in HTML, attaching some dom listeners.
So here's an example where I create a – I'm
creating a home custom control button, right?
So I'm just essentially, like I said before,
I'm creating a single Div element.
And I'm giving it some text and then I'm also
registering a dom event listener that when
I click on this div element, I want to set
the map center point to this home LatLng which
is some base, some, some, some hard coded
position.
In terms of positioning, so you have your
custom control created.
Now you want to position it.
Well, in V3, we don't really have a way for
you to absolutely position it anywhere although
you could try doing it by setting your, your
coordinates in your Div element.
But the way you do it with our API, well you
specify 2 things.
You specify the control position and then
you specify the index.
And so – the control position as you can
see in the diagram – there's different control
positions on the map where you can lay out.
There's these regions on the map which can
have these, these sets of controls.
And so for example, in this one on the top
right control position, we already have our
existing map type controls which is part of
the default map type which is one of our default
controls.
And so let's say you wanna, you wanna append
this home control there.
And then you specify an index.
You give the custom control an index.
Do I want it to be slotted at the zero position
or do I want it to be slotted to the left
after the existing control?
And so that's what -- it's doing it over here.
I'm placing my home button to the left of
my existing map type controls by setting its
index property to 1.
Next I want to talk about Directions.
Directions were completely revamped and there
was a huge overhaul in the way Directions
work in V3.
And in my opinion, there's a lot more structure
and it may seem like it's a lot more than
V2 but like I was saying before, sometimes
less code isn't more.
It's, it's more intuitive and it separates
your data from your presentation.
So here's how it was done in V2, right?
We had – you could only assign Map or HTML
container only once per any GDirections object,
right?
And then there's this really long request
string which has actually multiple pieces
of information in it, right?
It has your, your from point, your, your origin
and then it has your destination all in one
long string and that's just, that gets kind
of messy after awhile.
And then lastly in order to know when your
Direction Service returns back with a result,
you have to register an event listener that
listens to the subscure load event and that
just didn't seem very intuitive.
So in V3, we kind of redesigned everything
and we separated the various components of
directions into classes and so now you have
an actual start and end point which are properties
in object specification which you pass into
a constructor.
It also separates data from rendering.
We have 2 classes called Direction Service
and a Directions Renderer and one is simply
responsible for fetching data back and forth
from our API back end servers and the other
is responsible for taking that result and
then rendering it on a map or on the side
of a map in an HTML container.
So here's the really quick flow chart of what
a directions request – what that whole thing
might look like, right?
So we have this Direction Service object and
a Directions Renderer object.
The service takes through various properties,
through an object, it's a directions request
– it has – the request object can have
your origin, your destination point.
It can have your travel mode, your units and
so forth.
And that's going to kick off a request off
to our back end servers.
It's going to return back to you guys the
Directions Result object.
There's a junction point at that point.
With that result object, you can either choose
to parse it manually and go through – it's
a Jayson object – you can go through and
iterate the results and the routes yourself.
Or you can take that results object and say,
'You know what? I just want to put it on a
map and show it.
I want to give it to the Directions Renderer
object, pass it into there.
And if you assign your Directions Renderer
object an HTML element, it'll generate this
uniform UI – this list view of the directions.
Or if you give it a map object, it'll do everything
and it'll add poly lines and it'll add Info
Windows and add a marker for your start destination
point.
It'll do all that for you.
So that's what I mean when we separated the
data from the presentation.
So here's a, here's a quick example of what
- breaking down the steps even further – what
that looks like.
So here we have a Direction Service and you
can see the request options object is the
options object which has a bunch of properties
that you can configure your Direction Service
with.
So this will include – like I said – your
origin, your destination, whether to avoid
highways, if you want to avoid tolls.
You can specify a region that you want to
search against.
So you're passing that into Direction Service
and then you're calling this route function
and route is going to kick off this request
to our back end.
Back end is going to return back to you a
directions result object.
With this result object, you can, like I said,
do 2 things.
In this example, you're going to pass it into
the Directions Renderer object right?
And then you're going to give, you're going
to assign the renderer a map to visualize
this data on and you're going to assign it
an HTML container to visualize this data in
a list form.
And it's going to produce these results.
The other option, like I said, you can parse
it manually, right?
So let's say sometimes you don't want to,
you don't actually wanna, you just want to
extract some, some information from that Directions
Result.
So in this example, you can calculate for
example your first, your total distance of
the very first route that's returned in your
Directions Request and this doesn't involve
any UI at all.
So this is just you retrieving certain data
from that result.
[pause]
Okay so the last topic that I wanted to talk
about is actually I think the most fascinating
and interesting which is talking about MVC
objects and, and MVC framework and how you
can utilize this to really empower your applications
to go beyond and, and write more efficient
code.
So MVC is a UI framework which allows you
to isolate data from your input and presentation,
right?
So when I'm talking about data, I'm talking
about like your map and markers but not your
map, plotted on a map, right?
So that's like your view and you have this
concept where you bind your data to your views
and so forth.
So really quickly, what are – there's a
lot of objects in V3 that are basically extensions
of an MVC object.
And what is the significance behind that?
Well, if your object is an extension of MVC,
then it contains MVC properties which are
bindable.
What does it mean for a property to be bindable?
Well, if you have 2 MVC objects that are binding
one property – it's binding one property
of itself to the other MVC object property
– any time one of the values – any time
that property value changes, it's going to
automatically change the value of the other
property – of any properties that are binded
to it.
So, for example, if you have a marker and
it has a position property and you bind another
marker's position property to that and you
update the very first marker's position, it's
gonna, it's gonna update the second marker's
position as well.
So that might not seem very useful but I'll
show you an example of some ways – some
cool things you can do in MVC.
[pause]
So here's one example.
Let's say you have a circle overlay that you
want to bind to a marker.
And why would you want to do that?
Well, a circle overlay isn't draggable but
you know a marker is, right?
So if you want to make a draggable circle
for example, why not create a marker and then
have the circle overlay bind its center points
to the marker's position?
So anytime the marker's position gets updated,
the circle's centerpoint will automatically
get updated with it, right?
So the solution to this is, is to use an MVC
bind.
You can imagine what this looks like without
MVC.
You can do without it, right?
You can register an event listener that listens
for a marker drag event and every time the
marker gets dragged, you can update the circle
centerpoint.
And you can do that like this.
However, it's -- with MVC, all you need is
a single method, you need a single bind to
which says 'I want to bind this circle's center
property to the marker's position property'
and once you have that, I will show you what
this looks like.
You have a circle that now, when you drag
the marker, the circle's centerpoint will,
will be updated with it so you have this draggable
circle marker.
And you can imagine some use case where you
can, you can create a radius search bounding
box or something like that.
And that's kind of useful with this.
[pause]
So that was the first demo.
I did want to show another demo which I wrote
which included – I'm not sure there is a
practical use case to it but it does show
a little bit more about what you can bind
to and what are some of the effects you can
do, right?
So here we have a normal map.
And this map is highlighted – it's bordered
with red because I have a map here, I have
a circle here and I have a marker here.
And these are the head elements – head as
in the sense that I'm going to be adding new
markers and I'm going to be binding those
markers to this head marker.
Or I'm going to have new maps and then I'm
going to binding those maps to the head maps.
So it's going to be following whatever this
is doing.
So this is, this is nothing special.
You can see a marker that's being dragged
around.
If I add more circles, these are all draggable
as well.
But it gets more interesting when I add more
maps to it, right?
And in V3, I can add maps really quickly.
So let's see.
So within this map object, I'm – with every
map object that I create, I'm binding 3 things
to each other.
I'm binding 3 things to the head map.
I'm binding the zoom level so that when I
change the zoom level on any of them, it's
going to change the zoom level for all of
them.
If I change the map type, it's going to change
the map type for all of them as well.
And I've also binded, as my last property,
the center – the map centerpoint – so
that if I drag a map, it's going to drag the
map with it as well.
I've also registered a click listener on every
map so that when I click on it, it's going
to update only the head marker – only the
very first marker that was on here before.
It's going to update that map property so
that – there was the set map which, which
indicated which map your marker was binded
to but by updating that property, I can easily
switch between maps that my marker's gonna
be living on.
And because every new marker that I add, I'm
also binding that map property to the head
marker's map property, it's following – the
head – it's just following everywhere it's
going.
So this is another example of using MVC to
do something cool.
I'll leave it to you to figure out how you
can do this in V2.
It would be pretty messy.
And we don't have time to go over to the Twitter
search demo but if you want to see it, I can
show you afterwards.
So I did wanna really talk about what topics
that I haven't covered.
These are some of the things I haven't covered.
Like I said, there's a lot of V3 that is very
big and it's too – the session is too short
and I would love to talk to you guys for more
hours [laughs] about stuff but –
These are some of the topics that I haven't
covered.
And if you want to talk about them, you can
come see me afterwards and I will be happy
to tell you about them.
Then I want to talk – I guess so there's
other Geo sessions that are at Google I O
and I do want to encourage you guys to do
attend these interesting sessions.
So these are the ones that are happening today.
The 3:00 one is to be announced – there's
something exciting there so I would encourage
you guys to check that out.
Tomorrow, Thursday, we actually have our first
2 sessions are going to be focused on 3D mapping
and then 3:30 is a great session for you guys
if you are a V3 developer or you're a V2 developer.
3:30 session – Moving Beyond Markers – they're
going to talk about much more advanced topics
and what more advanced things you can do with
the Maps API.
And then there's a tech talk at 4:45 which
isn't very – isn't specific to map applications
but it's a general talk on how to develop
the cross platform API for both desktop and
mobile.
So lastly, I did have one last announcement.
And I did want to bring up that this is the
session that you want to go to if you want
to find out more information about this exciting
announcement and maybe you can guess what
that is.
[laughs]
Aerial?
Close.
Street View is now available for V3.
Yes so this is actually really big exciting
news.
[applause]
I know you guys have been waiting for this
for a while so thank you for your patience
and I would say that one of the reasons why
it took so long was because – well, it's
an amazing technology that's behind it.
This is completely a native browser support,
native browser technology which is being implemented
to implement Street View.
So there's no Flash Player involved or required
to run Street View.
And one of the reasons we decided to do this
is not because we're against Flash.
No, Flash is gonna be around, right?
It's because we know mobile browsers don't
support Flash, right?
So like the IPhone for example doesn't have
Flash installed.
So we want to be able to outreach and really
focus on, on bringing this experience to mobile,
to mobile phone and so – exactly.
HTML 5 canvas.
[applause]
Yes.
So lastly there's a developer qualification
– if you don't know about this, I did want
to just briefly mention it and say that if
you're interested in becoming a distinguished
expert in specifically the Maps API technology,
go to code dot google dot com slash qualify.
There's various ways to get qualified.
There's different things you can do to accumulate
points.
Some of the benefits of it I'd say, well you
get featured in our developer directory .
We have a developer directory on code dot
google dot com.
And it's really great for self promotion.
You can, you can promote yourself and you
can use the Google Qualified Developer badge
to do this and sometimes there's a preferred
or advanced invitation to some of our developer
events that we throw every year.
So check that out.
And lastly I wanted to remind everybody about
the notes that we've been taking on Google
Wave.
I'm going to be bringing them up now and I
will open it up for questions.
And if you do have a question, please use
the mic in the middle.
[pause]
>>Male Audience Member #1: I asked this question
yesterday…
>>Daniels Lee: Sure
>>Male Audience Member #1: about supports
for Sprites, for icons and mikers, and markers.
>>Daniels Lee: So Image Sprites are actually
already supported in your custom marker images.
We have a marker image class, class which
already allows you to specify an image sprite
to do that.
Yes and it's in the documentation.
[pause]
>>Male Audience Member #2: Hi and…
>>Daniels Lee: Hello.
>>Male Audience Member #2: congratulations
on Street View.
>>Daniels Lee: Thank you and you can congratulate
these guys up front.
>.Male Audience Member #2: Congratulations
you guys.
Does it work Flashless in IE?
>>Daniels Lee: Does..I'm sorry.
>>Male Audience Member #2: Does it work in
IE?
>>Daniels Lee: Street View?
>>Male Audience Member #2: Yes. Flashless.
>>Daniels Lee: Yes.
It should.
>>Voice in Audience: HTML 4?
>>Male Audience Member #2: HTML 4.
>>Daniels Lee: So Street View attempts to
use HTML canvas and SVG operations but if
it's not supported by the browser, it'll fall
back to HTML 4 which is supported by older…
>.Male Audience Member #2: There are questions
in Google Moderator and the Wave I was looking
at.
>>Daniels Lee: Hmm.
[pause]
Scroll up.
>>Male Audience Member #2: But it says nothing
there.
Oh well.
>>Daniels Lee: Oh, I have to refresh?
[audience laughter]
[pause]
[laughs]
So the question was will Flash be supported
moving forward and the answer is yes.
You're talking about the Google Maps API for
Flash, right?
Over Street View, in V2 it will be.
In V3 we don't have an existing Flash version
of Street View.
So this will be the Street View for V3.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Can you post to
your URL your map demos?
>>Daniels Lee: Yes.
I will post them on this Wave after the session
ends.
Okay.
I'll take a question from Moderator then.
So here's one.
Will the maps overlay from V2 also find their
way into V3?
[pause]
I'm not sure what – is the person who asked
the question in the room?
Hmm.
[voice from the audience] [bad audio]
>>Daniels Lee: Oh I see.
You're talking about layers, right?
The Wikipedia layers.
Umm.
[pause]
Hmm.
I believe we do plan eventually on supporting
layers which includes the Wikipedia layers
which is available in V2.
Yes.
[voice from the audience] [bad audio]
>>Daniels Lee: We do have some layers, right.
So yes.
Okay.
Are there still limitations to polygon rendering
and how has it been improved?
Hmm.
As far as I know, we are trying to constantly
improve the performance of polygon and polygon
rendering and so I'd imagine this being an
improvement.
Yes.
[laughs]
>>Ben: Speak into your mic?
>>Daniels Lee: Sure.
If you wanna.
>>Ben: It's gonna get weird.
Hi.
I'm Ben.
A Manager [ ]
I ported over the polygon code from V2 to
V3.
We've rewritten…
>>Audience member: Louder, louder.
>>Ben: Yeah.
Take it off.
[mic noises]
[voices from audience] [inaudible]
>>Ben: Much better.
Testing, testing.
Yes.
Okay.
So when we ported the polygon code from V2
to V3, we essentially rewrote a lot of it.
We now support many more polygons and more
complicated polygons.
We do client site level of detail.
If you have a really complicated polygon,
we'll figure out what vertices we don't need
to show up on the same level you're looking
at.
So it renders faster.
I think it's generally faster – a few niceties
as well.
Geodesics are now much smoother.
We now support polygons that include the North
Pole, the South Pole.
Yeah.
Let us know if you see bugs or performance
problems but we're pretty happy with it now
– the implementation of them.
>>Daniels Lee: Great.
Thank you.
Anybody in the audience have any questions
or…
I guess maybe I'll take time to take one more
from Moderator.
[pause]
>>Male Audience Member #4: Can you ask a show
of hands how many people are using V2 and
V3 in the audience?
>>Daniels Lee: Yes.
So the question – can I get a show of hands
of everyone in the audience that are using
V2?
[pause]
And how many of you guys are using V3?
Oh awesome.
How many of you guys will migrate to V3?
[laughs]
Great answer, great answer.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'll take one last question from Moderator
and then we'll conclude the session.
Umm.
Let's see.
[pause]
I guess we'll –
'What can I do to improve pan zoom performance
in, on V3 in mobile?'
Hmm.
It's an interesting question.
I'd like to know what is slow about it first
but I guess..
[pause]
Is that you?
>>Male Audience Member: That was my question.
>>Daniels Lee: Oh great.
>>Male Audience Member: So for example, if
you fire it up on an Ipad and you compare
it versus the Ipad native app and you pan
zoom in and out…
>>Daniels Lee: Oh I see.
>>Male Audience Member: It's really apparent.
One of them is going 'gunk, gunk, gunk, gunk'
and the other one's going 'zzzz, zzzz' .
>>Daniels Lee: So you're comparing the native..
>>Male Audience Member: It actually makes
those sounds.
>>Daniels Lee: You're talking about the native
app.
The map kit.
>>Male Audience Member: No.
I'm talking about…
I'm comparing and contrasting against the
native app.
But I wonder how – what can I do to help
my performance in the V3 browser version?
>>Daniels Lee: Hmm.
>>Male Audience Member: I want to make it
as close to native as I can make it.
As fast as I can go.
>>Daniels Lee: I would say that's a job for
our core API engineers.
[laughs]
I'm trying to think of techniques because
we don't really – in your own implementation
of your, of the application, it's not like
you're implementing the pan or the zoom effect,
right?
You're calling a Pan 2 or a Pan by function
or you're calling set center to relocate it.
Or on the drag, right, you're not doing, you're
not registering any or firing off any listeners
like that.
So really, it comes down to the core, just
the core UI interaction of how to pan and
the way the tiles are loading and so forth.
>>Male Audience Member: I have overlays also.
What effect do those have?
Like can I minify?
What sorts of things can I do?
>>Daniels Lee: So there will be some cost
in adding the overlays, right?
And creating the overlays.
But once the overlays are actually binded
to the map, that really wouldn't affect the
pan or zoom performance, in my opinion.
Unless on drag or unless on reposition, right?
Let's say you're listening for an idle event
which fires any time the map state changes
or if you zoom or if you change the center
location and you have that do something else
and add more overlays and that's going to
slow it down a little bit.
But just talking sheerly just about the pan
and zoom effect, there's not much you can
really do there.
But like you said, if you're adding overlays
and you do operations that are happening based
on that action, based on a pan, there's a
[inaudible] there.
There's ways to preload your overlays where
you can catch them or you can, or you can
be smarter about when you load them.
Or when not to.
>>Male Audience Member: Thanks.
>>Daniels Lee: Does that make any sense?
>>Male Audience Member: Mmm.
>>Daniels Lee: A little bit.
Okay.
Well thank you guys for coming and I really,
really want you guys to enjoy the rest of
your time at Google I O.
I look forward to seeing you guys around.
I will be hanging out on the Geo Developer
sandbox area or in the office hours so definitely
come talk to us.
Come meet us.
Thank you.
[applause]